spike we were uh uh he kind of pretty
much said it's better i asked you this
question since you were going through in
2020 yeah but
off camera we were actually giving
praise not you to aoc for aoc going out
there knocking doors because larry
knocked on your door so that to me shows
hustle when you look at lyndon johnson
back in the days when he ran for
congress the guy was known as a bmf who
was willing to come and sit down and
tell you i want your vote and that takes
a lot of work to do right shaking hands
doing all that stuff you know you were
in it you guys ran together you know
yourself and you i saw the bus i saw the
stuff that was going on what did you see
what do you think was the missed
opportunity and what was it like when
you were talking to people to convert
because the whole game is about
converting it's not to talk to people
that agree yes my biggest concern with
joe was when i spoke to her is how come
you haven't had many debates she
couldn't think about a debate so who's
pushing back who's challenging are there
people being converted i thought milton
did that but what did you feel was a
climate in 2020 i'm glad you brought up
that debate during the the joe interview
because and i do i think there was also
a big part of there was a lack of
messaging discipline when it came to and
this was something that i tried to do as
much as i could but i'm the vp candidate
you know it's not a 50 50 uh running
mate situation it's more like 95 5. um
so i did everything i could to talk
about lockdowns and the mandates and
everything else um
that wasn't the main focus of the
campaign unfortunately and by the time
the shift happened in in uh summer where
there was more focus on that it was too
late at that point and at that point a
lot of the lockdowns were waning too so
it was no longer the big thing everyone
was talking about um but i'm glad you
brought up the debates because uh the
reason we didn't participate in any
debates during the 2020 race was because
the campaign decided not to um obviously
we couldn't participate in the
republican and democrat the the
commission on presidential debates
debate because that was that's a cartel
and they keep everyone else out but
there were opportunities to participate
in debates with other third party
candidates and the campaign decided not
to
now i don't know why that was they said
it was because well we don't want to be
seen as being at the kids table
one percent two percent three percent
half a percent we're at the kids table
and we need to
take our position that we're at now
stand on the kids table and try to use
it as leverage to get up higher that was
a sort of microcosm of many problems in
the campaign we ran a really good
campaign for someone a candidate who was
already comfortably ahead by a couple of
points and uh you know didn't want to
rock the boat too much but if you're
trying to be a disruptive candidate
who's presenting a stark contrast to the
other two parties that wasn't being done
so so when that is happening how much of
counsel is being you know are they
asking you are you guys sitting in a
group is it a conference call is it a
zoom are you guys talking to each other
saying hey spike what do you see
happening what do you see is the
opportunity where are we dropping the
ball is is that mastermind taking place
or no uh the exact opposite was
happening uh i spoke with joe four times
during the campaign and i was told that
my opinions were not welcome what
but but let me let me uh how does that
how does that okay so who is uh there is
a spokesperson for the libertarian party
i i don't know the guy's name i've seen
him uh his name's
right here yeah no no no no no a guy a
guy
until you endorse he's right here right
yes but but the question i'm trying to
ask is like who's who's leading that
conversation isn't somebody sitting down
with you guys as a strategist and saying
hey
what are we is you were you really the
strategist leading that campaign no you
want to claim oh i'm talking about that
one yeah i'm going to talk about that
one before i get to you who was the
strategy whenever again but but i just
like never but but you know as as as a
person who's ran a business as a person
who's run a business and for many many
years as a
younger ceo entrepreneur i was afraid to
talk about the problems that we had sure
until i realized we can't do this [ __ ]
we got to talk about it let's get in
there and talk about it so unless if we
address that we can't get past it to get
to the next level so
who who was a i think behind closed
doors there's got to be some strategists
that are like you know to have some of
the who was that person for you guys
there was uh there were people called
strategists but it would there not so
much i actually had to build my own team
because there wasn't a lot of feedback
happening from the actual campaign
structure the the jorgensen campaign and
what little feedback i was getting is we
don't really want you to do anything or
say anything and we're not literally in
2018 i ran the biggest independent
campaign of 2018. we raised half million
dollars which is a lot for third party
right my opponents raised 6 million and
12 million respectively so obviously i
was blown out of water i built the
largest team
literally built a a policy library which
is still at larrysharp.com had a team
that got me on rogue and that got me on
glenn back that got me on all the shows
right
didn't ask me a question yep
did you actually want my team larry
actually offered
my entire game didn't happen i said take
my i built my team out i'm ready to go
let's go do this didn't happen didn't
happen and i'm doing it again now which
is why you said who's the person doing
it you're looking at the guy you go to
larryshop.com that is a libertarian
policy library you see what i'm doing
and i'm i i am in the least free state
as ranked by capable cato multiple years
in a row my policies have to lean
towards a horribly unfree state so
whatever state you're in you can easily
modify my policies and fit them in your
state if they can work in mine they can
work in yours we're the ones who get out
there and do things we're the ones who
are making things rock and roll so if
you're looking for the future it's here
i don't want to talk about the past
anymore well i by the way i don't know
how i don't have the past no no i said
it's here oh okay the future i don't i
don't know how new york beat uh
california i'm sure those cato guys have
an answer for it yes
so okay so you said if you go to my
website here's what i stand for why
don't you tell the audience what the you
run for governor new york as a
libertarian what do you stand for let me
bring up an answer to what to what um
dave brought up the answer is popularity
that's the answer
the answer i wish it was more that oh
i'm the smartest best-looking guy that'd
be awesome because i am both but that
doesn't matter the point is i have to be
more popular is the issue why can't we
get in debates debates are not about
whether someone is right or wrong
debates are about ad revenue that's what
debates are actually about so how do i
know that in new york when i ran i was
in debates right i've been in debates
with actual congress people i've been in
debates and i've gone back and forth but
there was a debate in new york state we
don't use a presidential commission we
actually use the league of women voters
and they had an actual official debate
and in that debate
our governor said i'm not showing up
why he was winning hands down cuomo was
the homosexual remember that was
homosexuals they all loved cuomo he was
going to win he's the best guy in the
world so he didn't bother showing up to
the debate so it wasn't televised so i
showed up republicans showed up two
other parties showed up and i wanted to
debate henley and no one saw it except
if he were there that was it because it
wasn't televised so what happened the tv
station said wait a minute there's a
bunch of money to be made so cbs said
we're going to do a special town hall
with just republican and democrat that
debate was televised
so if they think they can make ad
revenue they would do it remember in
2016
and 2017 cnn was in a bunch of
individual town halls with individual
people that wasn't because they cared
they were simply testing to see how much
money they would get in ad revenue if
any of them were popular they would then
put them in the debate stage it was
about popularity it wasn't about whether
they care or not the goal of the media
is to be seen and nothing else if we
understand that it's true
popularity matters people say larry how
come we didn't get in the polls because
you have to buy the polls to get in the
polls it's not about it's about cash
right so if i want to be in a poll
it's not just because i'm the official
candidate i found this out the hard way
i have to buy the poll a poll costs
about forty thousand dollars if i'm
raising millions uh i'll buy some polls
every week i'll buy a poll every month
i'll buy a poll when i'm raising half a
million dollars over my entire campaign
am i gonna be able to take ten percent
of that and throw it a poll and maybe
come in poorly
probably not it's not not a responsible
use of my campaign funds right so you
have to buy a poll well larry why aren't
you in the press why aren't you in the
press because you have to buy ads to be
in the press
if you buy ads they then cover you if
you don't buy ads they don't cover you
it's that simple it's all pay to play
people get mad at me why are you asking
for money because i have to buy ads so i
can be covered so i have to buy polls so
i can be in them otherwise you can't be
in the polls and that's why people don't
understand third party there are so many
things how much money did you say you
raised you raised half a million dollars
half a million dollars yes this is when
this is 2018 2018. okay so so
uh okay so i sit with private equity
guys and uh entrepreneurs will say when
i'm going around and i'm asking for
money and people are just not they're
not they're not giving me the money man
if they would have given me money i'll
be able to build the next billion dollar
opportunity
well maybe the messaging
or the product needs adjustment yep and
maybe the fundraiser the person
raising the money isn't doing a good job
selling whatever we need to get behind
because i like to take the uh what do
you call it i like to take the
responsibility on myself 100 and say hey
let's if we're not able to sell this guy
our our pitch is different so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]